an update now on that coal mine
Explosion in Turkey let's bring in Al
Jazeera Cinema who joins us from the
scene in a master in Northern turkey
synonym the death toll has been rising
bring us up to speed with the latest in
what's been happening on the scene there
well yes unfortunately the workers who
have been trapped by the minus 300 and
350 meter levels the deepest part of the
coal mine haven't been able to rescue it
alive as per the interior Minister who
just spoke half an hour ago he was just
here
two minutes ago and he spoke to Media
saying that the death toll has reached
the 26th and 14 more people have been
found that so the total number of the
Dead workers has reached a 40 and there
is one more worker left inside the mine
shaft and the interior Minister said
that the situation of this worker is
still unknown but they are searching for
him the uh the hopes for this worker is
not much actually we are seeing that
most of the workers who have been
trapped in this minus 300 and 350 meter
levels I haven't been rescued according
to initial indications the explosion
happened because of a fire death caused
by coal gas methane gas but this is the
initial finding and there's an there's
an uh there's an investigation launched
by the prosecutor's office that will
definitely tell us about what really
happened inside but the Mind experts who
have been speaking to Media since last
night have been saying that in order to
have inspired them due to a cold gas the
oxygen level and the mind should be down
below from 4 to 15 percent which can be
regarded as an election as they say the
coal mine behind me it belongs to the
Turkish State it's state-owned and
according to what the officials told
there were 110 workers on site yesterday
and 58 of them were rescued by the
rescue workers some of them by their own
own efforts as they were close to the
surface and now they are searching for
this last one worker and the families
are waiting for these workers 11 workers
are being treated in the hospitals and
some of the patients some of the workers
who've been wounded have been
transferred to Big hospitals in Istanbul
especially expertise in skin burns that
we understand that at this level the
workers faced fire and as for the
interior Minister there is a partial
fire yesterday they said there was no
fire but just half an hour ago in his uh
press conference interior Minister said
there's a partial fire on them so this
is a difficult situation the area this
region of North Eastern Turkey is full
of coal mines this Coal Mine having a
depth of 350 meter is not the deepest
actually in the area there are mines
going down at 1 000 meters but of course
this is a set situation in the area
especially for the people who earn their
lives from mining working in those mine
shafts and this is very difficult for
those people waiting for their men Sons
or husbands or fathers working in the
mines and having no guarantee so we are
trying to understand at the end of the
investigation whether there's a
neglection in this or the reason of this
explosion was something else okay thank
you so much for that update synonym
in northeastern turkey